[Musica]
[Applauso]
la storia dell'uomo è sempre stata
segnata dalle tecnologie dell'impatto
che hanno avuto sul nostro modo di
vivere di relazionarci gli uni agli
altri
dalla prima pietra che abbiamo
utilizzato come un utensile passando la
ruota per arrivare al petrolio
alcune di queste tecnologie sono state
silenziose pensate all'agricoltura
qualcuna più esplosiva pensate al
nucleare una nuova ondata tecnologica
sta cambiando tutto il nostro modo di
vivere
c'è un diluvio e questo diluvio è dato
dall intelligenza artificiale
l'intelligenza artificiale abita ai
nostri smartphone abita i sistemi
informatici abita tutto il modo di fare
le nostre cose
aiuta i medici a curarci meglio aiuta
anche la produzione industriale cambia e
cambierà il lavoro cambia pure il modo
di pensare il modo con cui possiamo fare
la guerra ma l'intelligenza artificiale
non è semplicemente qualcosa che aiuta
l'uomo nello svolgere i suoi compiti c'è
un tipo di intelligenza artificiale che
sostituisce l'uomo che fa al posto
dell'uomo prende delle decisioni al
posto dell'uomo
e allora di fronte a questo diluvio di
intelligenza artificiale
la domanda etica è fondamentale cosa
sappiamo di come decide una intelligenza
artificiale
quali sono i criteri che mette in atto
per compiere una decisione e chi è il
responsabile per quella decisione
dobbiamo parlare di etica delle
intelligenze artificiali ma per fare
questo dobbiamo sgomberare il campo da
qualche possibile fraintendimento
per qualcuno etica soprattutto etica
delle tecnologie è una sorta di catena
posta al collare di una macchina che
vuole correre che vuole andare sempre
più avanti se noi abbiamo l'etica così
come un qualcosa che semplicemente
limitativo
siamo in qualche misura sbagliando
bersaglio perché vedete l'etica della
tecnologia a che fare con quello che è
la tecnologia per l'essere umano 70 mila
anni fa quando dalla culla della nostra
civiltà
quando dall'africa noi ci siamo spostati
abbiamo colonizzato e abitato tutto il
mondo qualcosa di unico e di
estremamente diversa è successo per la
nostra specie
c'è un mammut spostandosi dalla steppa
siberiana per arrivare nel caldo
africano o nelle zone indiane ha dovuto
aspettare che gli nascesse un figlio
privo di quella folta pelliccia perché
potesse sopravvivere in un altro clima
in un altro ambiente
ecco noi 70 mila anni fa quando siamo
arrivati nella steppa siberiana ci siamo
vestiti della pelliccia del mammut
allora quello che per le altre specie è
dato nel dna
per noi è dato attraverso l'arte fatto
tecnologico l'artefatto tecnologico e il
modo con cui noi trasformiamo noi stessi
il mondo è il modo con cui noi che
abbiamo noi stessi e il mondo ma è
soprattutto il modo con cui noi lasciamo
alle generazioni future delle competenze
sul mondo allora parlare di etica e
parlare di tecnologia esattamente questo
e dire che questa cosa unica che è
dell'uomo che l'artefatto tecnologico è
costitutivamente etico è legata a delle
scelte ma quando arriviamo alle
intelligenze artificiali che tipo di
artefatto abbiamo davanti
ecco se l'avventura dell'uomo da 70 mila
anni a un'avventura fatta di artefatti
le intelligenze artificiali sono
artefatti botto robot decisamente
diversi dagli artefatti che abbiamo
fatto finora
se un programmatore prima era solito
programmare una macchina secondo un
paradigma che era if this then that se
accade questo fai quell'altro cioè se
prima a priori io devo pensare a tutte
quelle che erano le possibili occorrenze
in cui si sarebbe trovata la macchina e
offrire quella che era la risposta
adeguata
adesso le intelligenze artificiali non
sono così le intelligenze artificiali
affrontano problemi e ci offrono delle
soluzioni per questi problemi ma questo
cambio di paradigma
questa risposta che ci porta la macchina
ci porta a chiederci quella risposta e
corretta sta facendo il bene la macchina
ecco il giusto da fare in questo momento
è data scientist sono convinti che solo
una questione di dati quando avremo
database sufficientemente giusti
sufficientemente corretti le
intelligenze artificiali allora faranno
le scelte perfette non sono i primi ad
essere così ottimisti già la plus ce le
ha detto che il giorno in cui noi
avessimo conosciuto la posizione e la
velocità di tutte le
particelle del cosmo avremmo conosciuto
tutto il passato il presente e il futuro
questa conoscenza era il demone di la
plus
ma cosa sono i dati i dati vi possiamo
capire come una grande mappa della
realtà non tutta la realtà ma una parte
di questa se venendo qua io oggi avessi
usato il mio sistema di navigazione sul
mio cellulare
i dati che il sistema mi facevano vedere
non erano tutta la realtà perché se al
loro interno ci fosse stato tutte le
foglie tutte le persone tutte le
macchine in movimento
se quello che io vedevo fosse stata una
copia esatta della realtà
ecco sarebbe stato troppo complesso e mi
sarebbe stata inutile allora i dati su
cui decidono le macchine ma non solo i
dati che i sensori creano dalla realtà
non sono una copia esatta della realtà
ma una sua riduzione
e allora se i dati non potranno mai
essere la realtà un intelligenza
artificiale sarà sempre costitutivamente
fallibile gestire questa fallibilità è
questo il livello delle etica
dell'intelligenza artificiale riuscire a
dirci in che misura possiamo gestire
questa capacità di sbagliare di una
macchina che ora come lobo sapiens
diventa capace di agire ora l'uomo
sapiens a un nuovo partner che la
macchina sapiens ma come creare questo
dialogo tra l'uomo e la macchina sapiens
qual è il modo di procedere
beh quando noi compiamo un'azione siamo
consapevoli che sebbene noi decidiamo di
compiere qualcosa gli esiti non
dipendono tutti da noi c'è un esito
della nostra azione che non possiamo
prevedere dipende da tanti fattori c'è
un'incertezza che abita il decidere
ecco saper calcolare questa incertezza
saper dire a priori che le nostre scelte
tutte le scelte anche quelle fatte da
una macchina non sono
deterministicamente rivolte a quel
risultato è il primo linguaggio che
dobbiamo imparare per poter parlare di
etica l'etica nasce dove sappiamo che
c'è un incertezza nelle nostre scelte
ma non basta questa direttrice se noi
guardiamo alla storia recente se noi
guardiamo a quelle che sono state le
guerre
più sanguinose degli ultimi due secoli
le abbiamo fatte per dire che siamo
tutti uguali che non ci sono diversi
abbiamo fatte per dire che un sistema
sociale è giusto se consente ad ogni
cittadino di cercare la propria felicità
di mettersi in cammino verso quella che
è la propria autorealizzazione
e allora questa tensione tra uguaglianza
e ricerca della propria felicità è un
altro driver etico che non può essere
fuori dall'etica delle intelligenze
artificiali macchine che ci profilano
macchine che anticipano quello che sarà
il nostro comportamento che decidono per
noi mettono a rischio tanto la nostra
uguaglianza con il loro effetto scala
potremmo avere macchine che decidono chi
deve sopravvivere e chi no ma
soprattutto mettono a rischio la nostra
libertà ma se l'etica è questo se
l'etica e questo appello che arriva la
parte più profonda di noi sappiamo che
non basta l'etica i grandi regimi
totalitari
ci hanno detto che se non c'è un diritto
se non ci sono delle regole ecco l'etica
è una voce che arriva la parte più
profonda di noi ma come una voce può
essere ignorata e allora ecco che quella
voce deve diventare delle direttive deve
diventare qualcosa che plasma
l'innovazione dandole una forma che noi
vogliamo e siamo arrivati così al cuore
del problema
quello che dobbiamo fare per evitare di
vivere in una nuova forma di tirannia
una sorta di albo krazia è creare un al
gore tica e creare della una capacità
negli algoritmi di poter capire una cosa
che semplicemente umana quando noi
parliamo di etica noi parliamo di valori
e il valore una cosa morale è un
qualcosa che ci sorge dentro e che noi
riconosciamo nel nostro agire bene la
macchina anche parla di valori o lavora
sui valori ma sono valori numerici
rendere computabile un valore etico in
un valore numerico è la chiave di questa
alcol etica che potrà donare la macchina
sapiens una capacità di coesistere con
l'uomo sapiens senza minacciarne o
negarla il profondo valore
bene allora da qui possiamo delineare
quello che è il primo punto fondamentale
di questa etica
diamo la macchina un senso di incertezza
diamo la macchina mediante delle
librerie e statistiche la capacità di
riconoscere se certo no del risultato
che vede davanti a sé e sé questa
certezza non fosse piena
allora dovrà confrontare l'uomo per
validare la sua decisione
se facciamo questo stiamo creando un
intelligenza artificiale particolare una
human center e design
allora tenere il disegno il progetto con
l'uomo al centro è la prima direttiva
etica per mettere in pratica quanto fin
qui visto ma se questa è la prima regola
grammaticale
se questa è la base di questo linguaggio
come possiamo declinare questo nostro
parlare
beh quando noi lavoriamo con qualcuno
affianco a noi nel vederlo muoversi noi
capiamo qual è il suo obiettivo noi
capiamo cosa vuole fare anche la
macchina che vuole coesistere con l'uomo
deve poter possedere questo senso di
anticipazione deve capire qual è la mia
intenzione e accompagnarla nel suo
complesso compimento altri 20 avrò
qualcuno che va contro di me avrò
qualcuno che rischia di negare il valore
di cui sono portatori
un'altra questione che caratterizza il
nostro cooperare e che se io dovessi
guardare qualcuno di voi intento a fare
un'azione immediatamente capire qual è
il suo fine sta prendendo una bottiglia
d'acqua vuole prendere quel libro se io
guardo un braccio meccanico che compie
un'azione la programmazione ottimizzata
del braccio meccanico farà sì che
scarterà alla fine per prendere quello
che gli serve allora una coesistenza
dell'uomo e del robot richiede che la
macchina sia trasparente per l'uomo che
quelli che sono i fini del suo agire non
siano nascosti dietro un algoritmo
protetto magari da un copyright o da un
brevetto
io devo poter interagire con la macchina
devo capire quali sono i suoi fini ma io
e voi nun siamo esseri meramente
razionali non siamo solo volti ad
ottenere uno scopo a realizzare qualcosa
io voi siamo anche essere emotivi e la
nostra interazione con la macchina
avviene lungo questa frontiera di
emotività e allora supponiamo di montare
all'interno di una macchina guida
autonoma di un'automobile il modo con
cui quell'automobile guiderà nel
traffico produrrà in me una reazione
emotiva diversa
ecco la macchina deve adattarsi alla mia
risposta emotiva perché la mia emozione
il mio mondo dei sentimenti ha un valore
che è un valore unicamente umana la
terza caratterizza la terza
caratteristica è proprio questo
questo adattarsi della macchina alla
risposta emotiva dell'uomo rispettandola
tutelandola accompagnandola perché non
si sa mai un'esperienza traumatica e
infine quando un essere umano è una
macchina dialogano insieme coesistono
interno di uno stesso ambiente quello
che accade è che l'uomo ha degli
obiettivi la macchina degli obiettivi e
qual è il giusto obiettivo della
macchina lo decide la priorità dell'uomo
la macchina deve adeguare i suoi
obiettivi e le sue finalità a quelli che
sono gli obiettivi umani perché l'uomo
che in quel momento riconosce qual è il
valore e il valere del valore e dice al
valore qual è il primo da essere messo
in atto il primo da realizzare e allora
come fare e realizzare tutto questo ecco
solo se svilupperemo questo linguaggio
solo se la questione etica ritornerà ad
abitare al centro
questo nuovo artefatto l'artefatto
tecnologico autonomo le intelligenze
artificiali la macchina sapiens allora
potremo costruire insieme un futuro in
cui uomo e macchina potranno dialogare
aumentando le capacità del nostro fare e
non negando il valore che siamo grazie
[Applauso]